hey fire aah yay
that's how we do it that's how we do it
in the port-a-potty that's peacock dance
Pete okay no more energy drinks before I
record Jesus Christ
how's numbers we have a mansion key now
let's go and party hard
let's go on party hard girl which way
let's go to the mansion huh uh uh uh uh
uh then I just walked in through the
wrong direction I think yes because
there's the crying annoying lady could
you stop doing that
excuse me excuse me lady get the [ __ ]
out please you're not you're not getting
the [ __ ] out enough oh my god you're so
ugly you is one ugly ass [ __ ]
can we go in here can you die I'm
totally killing you here how many
snapchats do you need [ __ ] well [ __ ] my
life then this does not look like a
mansion anyway you hole that was
unnecessarily rude I feel terrible
let's keep going Mansion they said which
[ __ ] mansion that looks pretty big it
must be down here why yes yes of course
this looked like a mansion yes we found
it genius genius genie yeah maybe
there's something hitting in the bamboo
hello hello hello
No is it annoying that I do this let's
sit up pretty well so I don't know what
to tell you
all right what wait and what now instead
[ __ ] thanks it's like my god get in
life EBU Kotaku at a time all right cool
I agree with you three hundred thousand
percent good times
enjoyed it a lot [ __ ] a market Oh
uncool unfuckin cool that was the most
uncool thing I've seen in my life and
I've seen some uncool [ __ ] can we go in
here my god my tits just rocketed off to
space that's good one good champs
mansion key they said sit in here maybe
she will be here still it's locked now I
think I think I understand what we have
to do I think I have an understanding I
don't want to tell you yet because I
might be wrong and I'm probably gonna
look like an idiot but I do that every
day anyway so and and I try so hard it's
the lady here left no she's gone now
let's try and go in here really quick
Hey okay man dokgo we do go over high
heat dough cutter a hell of a day
she's she hair no she's not she's gone
now let's get for you
we still can't go inside so I don't
understand the purpose of this and why
would you put your house on top of those
that doesn't look very steady ooh
something going on over there what's
that okay that's creepy yeah yeah oh god
I hear something what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] are you you isn't ugly
stop you're so creepy creepy creepy
creepy
[ __ ] Catwoman die where's she
why is she why would you you is an ugly
[ __ ] you is an ugly ho how many how
many pics there's a woman taking her
dick seriously you're at way too close
to my face to be illegal boom bada bing
bada BAM bada boom bada bang bang bra
that's right suck my ass he's my [ __ ]
yeah that's that's great
maybe we're supposed to read the
documents files alright so that was
Paulo and a1 Paulo seek a hideous
manifestation of a powerful wish which
cool Amity anak alright hi John melodia
which dr. cool a power cone or what are
the babies then okay great stories I'm
learning here today is there anything
behind here nope absolutely [ __ ]
nothing
well we fought demons and we fought life
and I think we're gonna get just just
there just head back have a good time
have a good time in the less creepy
voice could this perhaps be the mansion
it looks pretty open though no that's
definitely not the mansion let's go
inside [ __ ] it [ __ ] it Yolo how low is
that as tree they have some majestic
trees in Indonesia I gotta say pretty
dope alright this must lead to a mansion
I mean camp on
should we go back to our ladies maybe
set it yeah we did it
high five but sorry is she dead
while good riddance she was annoying as
[ __ ] alright a new objective wonderful
come on don't be such a wimp come on
there we go we did it yeah yeah our
friend died awesome
great time hey this is kind of out of
the beginning started there Nate it's
very reminiscent citizen okay what's our
new objective going down here I think
yes good times how's everyone doing this
is great this is this great oh we're
here
awesome how's everyone doing
hey oranges a lot more in just other
heads oh well [ __ ] it
can you stop throwing potatoes too hey
he sucked on me it's [ __ ] gross oh my
god the jump scares man the jump scares
the jam scares gets me good every time
why I thought it was an e there we go
loading plus white man oh man oh man oh
man oh man oh man some ghosts can only
be seen through Linda's camera well we
play that there's much we know that much
we ain't stupid I mean I'm just saying
look that guy doesn't have a dick I have
an obsession with genitalia
I know I'm sorry oh hello we're inside
now I feel safe
how's everyone doing this is great all
right well I guess walking through the
main door is too [ __ ] easy so
Jennifer how are you doing buddy hey
putz love you you don't sound too good
ooh what's that how do we get inside oh
we can't just walk in all right cool
nice furniture nice Indonesian furniture
all right let's go let's go more how's
everyone doing hey what happened I heard
I heard a lot oh [ __ ]
who's in here I'm not afraid of you what
the [ __ ] is that sound hey girl
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stop oh [ __ ] is she in
the mirror okay this is really creepy oh
my god this is so creepy my tit hair is
like yeah
what's happening
mom-mom
I fell but why what if I keep thinking I
see something but Oh
she's holding me down ah what a [ __ ]
when when everyone sees this picture in
facebook they're gonna be like what hey
that's right ugly feet ah hey that's
just cuz you're ugly doesn't mean I
can't make fun of you hey girl what's
that sound everybody looks I better get
the other one too cuz I didn't really
get it did they it's that it's like that
I I think I watched an Indonesian horror
movie I don't know if it's in window
nation but it was [ __ ] amazing maybe
it was from the Philippines it's called
shudder or something
it's so [ __ ] good and and there's a
plot twist that's similar to this I
don't [ __ ] know okay you need us I
was snotting every way that's awesome
this is one break as well oh that's not
good
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die now I think
I died well is that my fault okay
probably was but [ __ ] I was not it
everywhere hey I have a cold
don't hate if you can't skate can you
skate No so don't hate bright is your
name bright it's not a name cool all
right well let's run to the carpet
your attempts the best times thoroughly
enjoy it ten out of ten would carpet
again I kinda I really like this game
even though it's so full of flaws
everywhere but it's still cool you know
I don't know I don't what telly man hey
let me take a picture [ __ ] boom [ __ ]
get out the way get out the way oh god
oh they're all so I had to get all the
mirrors i watch that's why I died let's
get out of here oh no it's the dining
hall this is really creepy actually I
don't wanna I don't like this don't like
to do this one bit oh god I hate when
there's aa guy there's too much stuff
going on here let's perform our solo
nailed it did the [ __ ] chair kill me
is she on top of me again I don't get it
[ __ ] it let's go upstairs a buffet no
don't get distracted I wonder if that
was a chair no I can't be it was huh it
just not on me if she's not writing me
huh how about that did you know
so it really was the chair of [ __ ] me up
thanks chair ah no it's just over here
hello oh my god I nearly died oh my I
broke all my legs all three of them just
oh we're back here alright well that's
don't hurt me again chair oh god I think
I see something
oh god we better hurry yeah me too get
started dammit guitar damnit guitar
[ __ ]
hey girl what's that sound everybody
looks what's going down hey stop the
charity nut well now you're just being
rude now you're just being a what the
[ __ ] attaboy attaboy what the [ __ ] I'm
going
Jesus Christ what do you what do you
want fine you win you win what are you
oh god these are all broken
I need another murder and that's I guess
a paw or your mirror stop stop stop stop
stop
listen you is about to be missing okay
we can do this press we can do this
Bruce I can feel it in my fingers
I feel it in my bro's we're gonna oh the
Sun is coming from here hello hello
sound it must be in this one then no we
checked all the doors guitar you [ __ ]
[ __ ] guitars man just [ __ ] me up
so good stop
no nice I don't understand
how do i how do I get past here can I I
could easily climb over let's be honest
here don't even give me that [ __ ] don't
even get me started on that hey yeah
it's that evil red lady that's locked
evil red lady sucks ass
damn it evil red lady that sounds like a
[ __ ] kitty hello
I mean I'm mentally challenged Kayla
kitty I swear to God I stopped sorry
that was offensive I didn't mean to say
it
don't kill me ghost don't kill me ghost
it's not my fault I'm I'm not good stop
stop then [ __ ] so much [ __ ] up over
there like I don't even know you're
gonna look so good on any filter I add I
mean so ugly whatever okay we need to
find a car we [ __ ] up or something
here so no a lot of cups
what are those yogurts oh man I love
Thai yogurt Indonesian ah
all the chairs is dangerous my god oh
wait that's not something oh my god
yeah I'm gonna get you on all the angles
[ __ ] boom got you on the couch [ __ ] I
don't like this Oh
oh [ __ ] you fumble me you're a table now
it yeah Oh
oh my got your table [ __ ] this is like
proper horror game edition my Fabrice
where are we
hey did it done it do it it battle lips
I'm gross I get it
Southie
hey we're back we're back up here
where the [ __ ] am i this is where we
fell down yeah yeah yes yes we must go
in here right yes did it got it do it it
battle it boom boom boom boom boom
hey this looks cut why is there no
reflection that's really strange
yeah well what are you gonna do I better
take a seat
why am I not reflect I went through
there watch what did I [ __ ] aback
about Ibaka that's some strange [ __ ]
what happens now
no oh there's something nearby
what II dress room key I didn't even
know I needed to go to the dressing room
that's it's quite interesting
all right I guess we go back through the
mirror of [ __ ]
all right well this has been great
oh now I have a reflection what
uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh I see I
see there's a faint ghost isn't it
they're right here but I can't with you
though they want what are you do what do
they want oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ
Oh what [ __ ] you why why I don't know
yes I will go
[ __ ] you your whole face you're my
potato I should be a rapper really
really I should be your rapper
shake that ass shake that ass for me
girl shake that a yes I have a problem
yes I do
all right so now we have a key for the
dressing room we Gondo it silicon big
good time we're gonna finish this [ __ ]
like we finish yo that's so good I
really should be a rapper enemy boxer
what's in here nothing great I love
nothing it's my
oh are you enjoying my commentary so far
then all I'm Clyde dressing-room it
could be any [ __ ] dear the game just
love making you run around like an idiot
this is the dressing room of course I
knew that I knew that wow that's like
radiant
lady in red [ __ ] off you're a dick bra
bra bra bra bra bra bra oh great
where is she Gracie why she oh where is
she
Oh oh god oh god oh god no I clicked I
swear I can't they all right it's fine
where is she oh all right way Chanel
where's yet where's she at though
where's yet Oh where's she at though
that's right I got you now [ __ ]
I look at my moonwalking oh god oh god
what oh it's always too late oh she's so
sassy
where's she at though
why it's getting bloody and [ __ ]
sidestep sidestep sidestep I see you oh
she changed oh my god Edgar's oh hey and
just farted and it's this worst smell I
ever smelt oh well don't change location
oh she's doing that [ __ ] thing again
oh oh I see you [ __ ] it's so red it's a
radar dancing raining oh I'm kicking her
[ __ ] ass
how much more ants are you gonna suck
okay okay oh she's there yay
that time we do it that's how we do it
in the port-a-potty every day and speech
okay no more energy drinks before I
record Jesus Christ what just [ __ ]
happened all right I just get really
excited when I think I can't do
something and I do it and it makes me
Hey ayyy
I like ideas I like a disallowed mm-hmm
let's check this out cutscene
uh-oh why are we doing this no don't sit
don't sit down bad idea Bab a bad idea
um I like I she's covering her skirt
good call
it's it getting darker it's just this is
just more why are we just sitting here
oh so she can creep up on us but she's
nice right
I think titty girl is nice block well
that does it
I am never having any more massages in
my life I don't hug myself that's really
gay not that there's anything wrong with
that of course all right well video
games video games video games video
games video games video games video
games video games video games video game
video games video games pretty good I
would say all right it continues
hallelujah look at me
I was really creepy they nailed the
creepiness in this game I've gotta say
and thoroughly creeped out good job game
hey we're back in this building how
about that you bros remember ah no I
don't I don't I don't want to go in this
damn it no I don't like
you go away ah Shh
stop stop yeah that's right fly over
there that was [ __ ] ah [ __ ] it about
gotta Boca what happened [ __ ] no far
away from me please
it's really it's really it's really dark
isn't it I see you say [ __ ] off
oh god why'd she go
this is [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] no I see
her yeah that's right come back come
back become oh god don't move don't move
don't move I'm gonna be fabulous
okay where's she go where did she go I
don't see her
don't ah that's all don't see her see
you hi
bye how many times I'm gonna have to do
this I don't like this I don't enjoy
this video games oh god oh god she's
faster than sanic oh I think that fish
melted of maggots wow that's nice oh
it's that was you it was just you being
an [ __ ] again alright well take me
then take me down to the Paradise City
where the grass is green and they oh
well I'll guess I'll never know what are
you why all right
you mean you're [ __ ] mean alright
stop
listen your ass is about to be missing I
will be pissing what would i okay just
just gonna just just
maggots pitch you a maggot [ __ ] you a
mega mega mega [ __ ] you a mega [ __ ]
I'd exploded the lighting in the space
oh that's that's some kinky [ __ ] right
there
all right there that's that's kinky I
like it this game should make a you are
coming near me I don't I don't I don't
yeah she's sucking me up and don't you
dare die take me down to the maggot city
where the maggots are green and the
girls are that's not the Larry existed
I'm so close come on let me out you
really [ __ ] mean do you know that we
can't even go up there all right well
I'm gonna die now no stop stop I swear
to God I swear to God
oh we can shoot her that's right
I shoot you I don't know how many times
but at least a couple great why did she
go no it's up I swear to God why is she
[ __ ] you oh no she trapped me oh there
she is Hey ugly you is ugly it's for our
nice hands I like it like it a lot you
messed with the wrong photographer today
brat Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
para Popham but a Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam
done tan tan tan tan tan tan tan did we
do it never do it if it did a little
Google dick believe everybody but they
opieop there the door is unlocked Wow
high five go in [ __ ] this place oh well
let's yell oh [ __ ] it oh alright
that's see ya later alligator
[ __ ] haole
fight me come at me bro
that's right I got my film is never
ending its die
come on the dress is so 2011
how could you wear it everyone's gonna
laugh at you now and your fingernails
yeah they look like they haven't been
properly many cured it's just hot girls
this is work I don't she dead yet you
pissing me off yeah it's I know you
think it's funny that you're dying but
it's this [ __ ] weird alright she's
seriously not dying on me right now well
I guess I'll go into a piss then
I don't know how many shots she wants me
to take out of her this is getting kind
of awkward
did I miss something oh [ __ ] why my
balls just fell off man man oh man buddy
no no no no no don't touch me don't
touch me don't touch me that that's
great don't touch me please
don't dude don't you touch me don't you
touch me Channel we're going back out no
no no no no oh god oh god okay Plan B
[ __ ] you are you [ __ ] kidding you
best be [ __ ] with me right now
this is not a funny joke this is not
very funny one this is so [ __ ] creepy
and annoying just just learn how to door
handle woman can you stop please stop
she looks like she's dying okay just
gonna go past you now cuz you're pissing
you off so much all right well I'll run
out again
all right well I'm okay I'm so what's
going here you're you're fast now I
don't like that stopping all right this
way
cool this is really [ __ ] weird isn't
it
don't hurt me I'm Swedish Swedish people
don't like to get feelings hurt she's
right behind me isn't she
stop stop don't like it it is alright
thanks
can I you see my other phone maybe this
is way better this is way better
dead end cool that's it's really what I
was hoping for
oh this Aldous go this way thank you
she's really creepy and I don't like it
alright
ah [ __ ] this does not look right this
looks right let me go I will be your hoe
I promise I will [ __ ] anyone any mo let
it go I'm a Pokemon [ __ ] off you little
bow hey a dinosaur that's what I wanted
a dinosaur yes okay it's over thank you
please please don't kiss me I love you
baby
all right she likes to hug I guess who
doesn't well oh she's in front of us on
the carpet no no no you can't you can't
take our life no no no Ned don't
don't interrupt you mean
Oh
oh that's very nice very nice yes
what's going on
she got me or one I thought I'd take a
picture of the dinosaur are those chains
ah come on
oh I was Savin
where are we now I'm so confused what
she's not dead
she's a baby now
let me see that pretty baby
[ __ ] those tiny little hands man nice
leggings
out
nice
should anything surprise this woman at
this point all the maggots
or well that's kind of [ __ ] up isn't
it stupid mermaids stupid mermaids
waitwhat that's the atchoo in
but
really
there's no egg three I just call it
quits I get that I guess we kind of
defeated the red lady I thought for sure
it would be three acts at least well I
don't know what to tell you I feel like
I mean here's the thing it has you can
tell the people who work on it have a
good sense of horror that I feel like so
many gained horror games that I play
don't have they just put a bunch of
[ __ ] notes in there and be like
that's a horror story just read these
notes and it's just a wing I don't know
I'm really annoyed by most of the stuff
I played recently but you can tell it at
least they understand in a better way
decorum but still it's so flawed and I
felt like this could be so much more I'm
not saying it's bad I just feel like it
should be more [ __ ] I expected more and
not really I mean it's an indie game
after all their budget was kind of
limited as was and as you can see
there's so many people working on it but
I don't know I think it could have been
cooler but it wasn't bad I think it was
I enjoyed it a lot so [ __ ] who cares
and I think they should they should let
me or someone else play testing before
is there so many thing you like Nitin
wait-wait a minute
then this is making me sense I feel like
so much effort was just wasted on
cutscenes it'd be like why is there
another cutscene here we don't we don't
need that you don't have to animate all
this don't don't worry man it was cool
it was so cool I enjoyed it good job
whoever made it you were great
I will love to check out whatever the
[ __ ] else YouTube and stuff
all right well then thank you both for
watching this two-part series of act 2
it's kind of interesting we started
playing the demo this I think more than
two years ago it's kind of [ __ ] crazy
do you remember have you watched that
one time [ __ ] flies man
it's crazy Norwegian people helped out
on this or Danish yeah Danish Danish
people did something how about that I
make that joke every time and everyone
gets equally offended yeah I'm gonna go
but I want to thank you both for
watching and always being there and
showing your support and it's all like
gmail.com like we know your emails but
you have to put that there
all right double kiss hey cuz the
brofist stay awesome bros mah ha-ah oh
saying there's a movie let's watch it
Slenderman
she's like headphones on
I don't even be giving them on the phone
she's a meanie the teaser for the next
scammers I'm [ __ ]
yeah we're tired of dread out this is
this is launch another game [ __ ] it [ __ ]
two part three
no one wants that [ __ ] right uh what the
[ __ ] what was i seriously
alright oh I'll leave here